[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen zu 20
Minuten Nachrichten und klar auch mit
dem Sport von Norbert Lehmann einen
schönen guten Tag von mir schauen wir
unsere Themen
was taugt das neue heizungsgesetz
Regierung und Opposition hören Fachleute
zu den geplanten austauschregeln
Zeichen gegen Gewalt Franzosen
versammeln sich vor ihren Rathäusern und
fordern ein Ende der Ausschreitungen
und Juniorinnen Spieler und Fans feiern
in Berlin den WM-Titel der deutschen U21
Handballer
beim heizungsgesetz hat die
entscheidende Woche begonnen die
Ampelkoalition will es bis zur
parlamentarischen Sommerpause
verabschiedet haben und das heißt die
Zeit drängt heute gab es eine Anhörung
von Fachleuten im zuständigen
Bundestagsausschuss Ende der Woche soll
dann der Bundestag über das Gesetz
abstimmen und auch der Bundesrat muss
noch grünes Licht geben Butter Buchholz
die Experten hatten ein lese intensives
Wochenende 110 Seiten komplexes Gebäude
Energiegesetz mussten durchgearbeitet
werden fast alle halten die Eile für
falsch die Änderungen aber für richtig
ob Kritik bleiben sozialer Aspekte wenn
eine Härte vorliegt dann liegt die beim
Mieter vor es mag auch welche beim
Vermieter geben das bestreitig überhaupt
nicht aber wenn die beim Mieter vorliegt
ist es furchtbar egal aus welchem Motiv
heraus der Vermieter die Maßnahme
durchführt die Härte ist da
umstrittene Punkte die Ausnahmeregelung
für über 80-jährige wurde gestrichen sie
wäre wohl verfassungswidrig die
Grundförderung beim Umbau beträgt 30
Prozent der Kosten unabhängig vom
Einkommen und für Mieter gibt es zudem
Grenzen bei der Mieterhöhung viele
strittig doch Zeit bleibt wenig
kritisiert die Opposition es sind viele
Fragen offen es würden zahlreiche
Hinweise gegeben und es wird unmöglich
sein in den wenigen Stunden bis zur
Ausschusssitzung am Mittwoch die sie
solide zu bewerten die Ampel Koalition
will dagegen am Zeitplan festhalten die
FDP zeigt sich nach vielen Änderungen
zufrieden diese inhaltliche
Auseinandersetzung war außerordentlich
wichtig hätten wir diese
Auseinandersetzung nicht gehabt hätten
wir es heute mit einem anderen Gesetz zu
tun gehabt
Umweltverbände befürchten aber dass die
Pariser Klimaziele durch das neue Gesetz
nicht eingehalten werden
das neue GEG ist eine Lebensversicherung
für die gaslobby auf Kosten der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und auf Kosten
der Natur was wir ganz stark kritisieren
ist die erhöhte Verbrennung von Holz die
es dadurch geben wird am Freitag soll im
Bundestag das Gesetz verabschiedet
werden nun soll sehr schnell gehen um
was lange gestritten wurde
und nicht nur über das sogenannte
heizungsgesetz haben die
Koalitionsparteien erbittert gestritten
auch über den Haushalt 2024 das Motto
des Finanzministers fürs nächste Jahr
lautet sparen sparen sparen um das Loch
von 20 Milliarden Euro zu schließen und
die Schuldenbremse einzuhalten der
Entwurf fürs nächste Jahr sieht Ausgaben
von
445,7 Milliarden Euro vor die
Neuverschuldung soll bei 16,6 Milliarden
Euro liegen zwei Tage vor der geplanten
Verabschiedung des Entwurfs im Kabinetts
gibt es weiter Streit über die
Finanzierung der Kindergrundsicherung
Heikes Lanzke dazu in Berlin was genau
ist denn das Problem bei der
Finanzierung der Kindergrundsicherung ja
das Geschacher um die Kinder
Grundsicherung geht ja bereits seit
Monaten im Kern dreht sich der Streit um
die Frage ob es mehr Geld für
armutsgefährdete Kinder in Deutschland
gibt als die zwei Milliarden die
Finanzminister Lindner als Platzhalter
vorsieht konkret mit der
Kindergrundsicherung sollen staatliche
Leistungen ab 2025 gebündelt werden also
das Kindergeld für alle Plus für
einkommensschwache Familien der
Kinderzuschlag stellt man das System um
von einer hohe Schuld der Familien auf
eine Bringschuld des Staates sprich dass
der Staat verpflichtet wäre auf
Ansprüche hinzuweisen dann so glaubt der
Finanzminister während etwa 2 Milliarden
mehr nötig da viele Leistungen von
hilfsbedürftigen gar nicht abgerufen
werden
Familienministerin Paul will aber
mindestens 12 Milliarden in die Hand
nehmen um Kinderarmut wirksam zu
bekämpfen also eine grundsätzliche Frage
die im Moment noch verhandelt wird und
an deren Ergebnis die Grünen ihre
Zustimmung zum Haushalt knüpfen wollen
vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung
schauen wir nach Polen wo
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius zu
Besuch ist dort geht seit Beginn des
russischen Angriffskrieges auf die
Ukraine durchaus die Kriegsangst um
deshalb will Polen seine Ostgrenzen noch
stärker sichern wie aktuell zu Belarus
wegen der geplanten Verlegung der
russischen wagnersöldner
an der Grenze zur Ukraine in Samos
besuchte Pistorius heute die seit Januar
stationierten 320 deutschen Soldaten und
Soldaten sie bedienen das deutsche
Patrick Flugabwehrsystem es soll Polens
Luftraum schützen aber auch die NATO
Luftverteidigung an der ostfranke
Stärken wer von ihnen
kurz vor der Grenze zur Ukraine der
deutsche und der polnische
Verteidigungsminister bei den
patriots-systemen die Deutschland stellt
50 Ziele können die jeweils im Blick
behalten und fünf Objekte gleichzeitig
bekämpfen es gilt Waffenlieferungen in
Richtung Ukraine zu schützen und aktuell
auch die Grenze zu Belarus
wir wissen sagt Mario sportczak wie die
Situation in Belarus aussieht wir wissen
von der wagnergruppe und deren Aktivität
wir müssen aktiv sein um Bedrohungen die
Stirn bieten zu können mit Blick auf die
deutschen Patriots möchten wir gern dass
sie bleiben zumindest bis zum Ende
dieses Jahres Anlass für die
Stationierung ein Raketeneinschlag auf
polnischem Gebiet im November vorigen
Jahres Berlin wohnt daraufhin die
Patriots an drei Systeme wurden verlegt
allerdings erst nach einigen politischen
hin und her mit Warschau seit Januar
sicher nun auch sie die Ostflanke
mögliche Bedrohungen können dabei
fehlgeleitete Raketen sein und das ist
dann auch das zielspektrum welches wir
im Falle eines Falles bekämpfen würden
am Morgen die Begrüßung der beiden
Minister freundschaftlich doch das
deutsch-polnische Verhältnis angespannt
Streit gibt es aktuell um eine
Reparaturzentrum in Polen für Leopard
Panzer die in der Ukraine im Einsatz
sind ich bin der Auffassung dass jetzt
die Zeit drängt deutschland ist bereit
Verantwortung zu übernehmen so oder so
und deswegen sind wir der Auffassung
dass die Gespräche möglichst innerhalb
der nächsten 10 Tage beendet werden
sollten von einem kleinen guten Schritt
in die richtige Richtung sprechen Sie
bei der Verabschiedung nächste Woche
NATO-Gipfel auch da steht der Schutz der
Ostflanke ganz oben auf der Agenda
blicken wir jetzt nach Frankreich seit
dem jüngsten Fall tödlicher Polizei
Gewalt kommt es dort ja zu Protesten und
Unruhen dabei entladen sich auch Wut und
Frust über soziale Benachteiligung und
Rassismus auf den Straßen wer in
bestimmten Vierteln aufwächst ist er von
Arbeitslosigkeit Armut Chancenlosigkeit
betroffen einige Fakten dazu von Axel
Konrad
günstiger Wohnraum für
Geringqualifizierte und Geringverdiener
dafür wurden in Frankreich schon in den
50er Jahren in den Großstädten riesige
Hochhaussiedlungen gebaut mal wie hier
in Marseille mitten in der Stadt meist
aber außerhalb der Zentren sowie in
Paris
5,2 Millionen Menschen leben heute in
solchen Vierteln überwiegend Einwanderer
schon früh wurden die Quartiere zu
Sammelbecken für die sozial abgehängten
und so sind sie auch zum Sinnbild für
eine misslungene Integration geworden
wer hier aufwächst hat deutlich
schlechtere Chancen als im Rest der
Republik das belegen diese Zahlen
die Arbeitslosenquote ist mehr als
doppelt so hoch bei den Männern
2022-19,6% gegenüber 8,8 im
Landesdurchschnitt die
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit liegt in vielen
der Problemviertel gab jenseits der 40%.
und die Armutsquote 2020 lag sie bei
mehr als 42% gegenüber 17 landesweit der
bildungsdurchschnitt ist schlechter mehr
als die Hälfte der Jugendlichen hat
gerade mal den niedrigsten Abschluss
in den vergangenen Jahren gab es immer
wieder Unruhen in diesen Vierteln oft
nach Fällen von Polizei Gewalt der
Unterschied heute die Jugendlichen sind
deutlich jünger oft Kinder sie agieren
in kleineren Gruppen und stimmen sich
über soziale Netzwerke ab
auch in der vergangenen Nacht gab es
wieder Ausschreitungen aber sie waren
weniger stark als zuvor der französische
Präsident macron will sich morgen mit
220 Bürgermeisterinnen und Bürgermeister
von Gemeinden Treffen in denen es
Unruhen gab über die Lage und den Umgang
der Regierung damit berichtet Anna
Warsberg
der Innenminister zeigt sich mit den
Menschen solidarisch und lässt sich
zeigen was sie in Ras am Wochenende bei
den gewaltsamen Krawallen alles zerstört
wurde
ich denke dass die öffentliche Ordnung
jetzt erstmal wieder hergestellt ist
aber es ist noch nicht zu Ende die
Polizei wird auf Wunsch des Präsidenten
in den kommenden Nächten weiterhin
extrem mobilisiert sein auch wenn es in
der Nacht mit einigen Ausnahmen sehr
ruhig war
die Regierung will Stärke und Härte
zeigen 45.000 Polizisten waren letzte
Nacht in Frankreich Städten und
Vorstädten unterwegs Jugendliche und
Staatsgewalt stehen sich vielerorts
weiter aggressiv gegenüber
der getötete war ein Jugendlicher
deshalb sind hier so viele junge
Menschen wie unterstützen das denn es
ist ungerecht und die Polizei
schikaniert uns ständig der Tod des
17-Jährigen nail durch den Schuss eines
Polizisten letzte Woche war Auslöser für
die Proteste die Wut der Randalierer
richtet sich vor allem gegen die
Behörden Zerstörung trifft alles
in einer Kleinstadt bei Paris wurden der
Bürgermeister und seine Familie am
Wochenende
Opfer eines mutmaßlichen Brandanschlags
der bürgermeisterverband hat daraufhin
heute zu einer landesweiten
Solidaritätsbekundung aufgerufen
wir lassen uns nicht einschüchtern lasst
uns die Ärmel hochkrempeln und jetzt mit
der Arbeit beginnen gemeinsam werden wir
dem Stand halten
Präsident macron hat für Dienstag mehr
als 220 Bürgermeister in den
elise-palast eingeladen die Aufarbeitung
soll beginnen
israel hat eine groß angelegte
Militäroffensive im Best jordanland
gestartet nach mehreren Luftschlägen
rückte die Armee mit Bodentruppen in die
palästinensische Stadt Chinin ein mit
dem Ziel terroristische Infrastruktur zu
zerstören sagte ein Militärsprecher
mindestens acht Palästinenser wurden
getötet denien und das dazugehörende
Flüchtlingslager mit allein rund 11.000
Menschen gilt als Hochpunkt militanter
Palästinenser Michael
kurz nach Mitternacht in Jenny als
Israels Militäroperation beginnt die
größte Invest ja dann Land seit dem Ende
der zweiten in die Fada 2005
über 1000 Soldaten sind im Einsatz
Kommandos durchkämmen das
Flüchtlingslager greifen nach
Armeeangaben Terroristen und deren
Infrastruktur an den ganzen Tag ist
Gewehrfeuer zu hören
und die Motoren der Drohnen
die greifen zusammen mit
Kampfhubschraubern aus der Luft an die
Bilanz mindestens acht Tote und dutzende
Verwundete
wir treffen ein terroristisches Zentrum
mit großer Stärke ich möchte betonen
dass wir keinen Kampf mit den
Palästinensern führen
die Palästinensische Autonomiebehörde
hat seit langem die Kontrolle über
Städte wiegen oder nahtlos verloren kann
nur noch zuschauen
israel hat heute morgen wieder einmal
ein großes Verbrechen in Genin begangen
auch große Teile der zivilen
Infrastruktur seien zerstört worden was
als Demonstration der Stärke gedacht ist
zeigt doch nur Israels Ohnmacht
vollmundig hatte Israel
Sicherheitsminister Benk wir vor den
Wahlen Ruhe und Ordnung versprochen in
Israel und
investia-opfer wie seit Jahren nicht
weder ist ein Ende der Operation
absehbar noch was sie erreichen wird
Terrororganisationen wie Hamas und
islamischer Jihad haben bereits
Vergeltung angekündigt
zurück nach Deutschland in Bremen sind
die politischen Weichen für die nächsten
vier Jahre gestellt sieben Wochen nach
der Bürgerschaftswahl haben SPD Grüne
und Linke ihren neuen Koalitionsvertrag
unterzeichnet im Mittelpunkt der
Regierungsarbeit soll vor allem die
Bildung stehen das Dreierbündnis will
Kitaplätze für alle anbieten mehr
Grundschulklassen sollen zwei Lehrkräfte
bekommen ein weiteres Ziel ist die
Modernisierung des Hafens übermorgen
soll der SPD-Politiker bogenschulte dann
als Bürgermeister wieder gewählt werden
rund 64 Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland haben sich bisher gegen
Corona impfen lassen und in einigen
Fällen gibt es Nebenwirkungen über das
Risiko wurde jeder und jeder vor der
Impfung aufgeklärt deshalb besteht
grundsätzlich kein Anspruch auf
Schadenersatz es sei denn es handelt
sich um eine ungewöhnliche bisher
unbekannte schwere Schädigung dann kann
man den Hersteller verklagen das wird
jetzt in mehreren Prozessen versucht Jan
Henrich berichtet
Prozessbeginn in Rottweil gegen den
Impfstoffhersteller biontech der
58-Jährige Kläger sagt er habe durch die
Impfung Sehkraft verloren und fordert
150000 Euro Schmerzensgeld
sie ist ja wir wollen solidarisch der
Pandemie die Stirn bieten und jetzt ist
Zeit und Gelegenheit hier aus Worten
Taten werden zu lassen das heißt den den
ist nicht so gut gegangen ist nach der
Info eine gewisse finanzielle
Entschädigung zukommen zu lassen und
eben die Anerkennung dass es dann eben
Schaden war Bayern Tag bestreitet den
Vorwurf wir haben die vom Kläger
dargestellten gesundheitlichen
Beeinträchtigungen auf der Grundlage
aller zur Verfügung gestellten
Informationen sorgfältig geprüft und
sind zu dem Ergebnis gekommen dass die
Klage unbegründet ist
offiziell anerkannte im Schäden nach der
corona-impfung wie etwa bei einer
höheren Venen Thrombose oder einer
Herzmuskelentzündung sind extrem selten
bei über 64 Millionen in Deutschland
geimpften gab es bis Anfang Juni nur
rund 300 bestätigte Fälle und selbst bei
bestätigten im Schäden ist eine Haftung
der Konzerne eher unwahrscheinlich die
Hürden für Schadensersatz Ansprüche sind
hoch denn dafür müsste nicht nur der
Schaden auf die Impfung zurückzuführen
sein
die Beeinträchtigung über bekannte
Nebenwirkungen hinausgehen sondern auch
das Risiko der Impfung insgesamt müsste
größer sein als deren Nutzen
rechtlich ist ganz klar wenn Hersteller
wie bei biontech bei der Entwicklung und
Herstellung des Impfstoffs keine Fehler
gemacht haben sind sie im Prinzip raus
aus der Haftung und das gilt auch wenn
einzelne krasse Impfschäden auftreten
zumindest solange insgesamt der Nutzen
der Impfung überwiegt und genau davon
gehen bislang Behörden und Gerichte aus
dennoch klagen aktuell viele mutmaßlich
impfgeschädigte vor Gerichten in ganz
Deutschland
und jetzt zum Sport Norbert die
deutschen U21 Handballer sind
Weltmeister und zwar sowas von verdient
30 zu 23 gestern Abend in Berlin im
Finale gegen Ungarn und wieder eine
mitreißende Galavorstellung der jungen
deutschen Handballer die bei diesem
Turnier gezeigt haben das ist Spieler
Nachwuchs mit großen Potenzial
Deutschlands U21 Weltmeister im
Partyrausch acht Spiele acht Siege ein
perfektes Turnier im Finale gegen Ungarn
nagelte Elias Scholtes mit der
halbzeitserie den Ball zur 14.11
Pausenführung ins Netz Mannes abends
wieder einmal Torhüter David Spade von
den Rhein-Neckar Löwen der mit mehr als
40% gehaltener Bälle überraste wir sind
eine mega geile Truppe jeder freut sich
für jeden und ist egal
Weltmeister und das Zelt diese
Mannschaft hat Zukunftspotenzial auch im
Angriff Kreisläufer Justus Fischer war
mit sechs Treffern erfolgreichster der
deutschen Mannschaft ebenso wie
Rückraumspieler Elias Schultes der auch
sechs Mal traf es scheint als wächst
hier eine goldene Generation im
deutschen Handball heran
[Applaus]
zum Grand Slam Tennisturnier in
Wimbledon da sind zehn deutsche am Start
einer Friedsam ist als erste
ausgeschieden Maximilian Marterer
dagegen ist eine Runde weiter
mit einem Ast beendete der 28-Jährige
Nürnberger das Match gegen den Kroatien
mit sieben zu fünf sechs sieben sechs
drei sechs vier die Partie musste
übrigens wie andere Spieler in diesem
Tag auch wegen einsetzen im Regen
unterbrochen werden
zur Tour de France heute die dritte
Etappe das größte Radrennen der Welt hat
nach dem Start im spanischen Baskenland
Frankreich erreicht erster im Ziel von
bion der Belgier Jasper Philipsen und
ganz knapp dahinter der deutsche Film
Bauhaus
eingeschlossenes Feld auf den ersten
Kilometern in Frankreich keiner wagt
noch einen Ausreißversuch bion erlebt
den erwarteten Massensprint auf der
Innenseite schiebt sich der Belgier
Jasper Philips sind vor und holt sich
nach zwei Erfolgen im Vorjahr seinen
dritten Etappen Sieg eine schnellere
Schussphase jedoch zeigt den weißen
Trikot viel Bauhaus bei seiner ersten
urteilnahme gleich ein zweiter Rang für
den 30-jährigen Mann aus Bocholt
natürlich wurde das Ergebnis
drüber freuen aber
wenn man so nah dran ist dass man
natürlich auch ein bisschen enttäuscht
der Brite Adam Yates bleibt auch nach
der dritten Etappe im gelben Trikot des
gesamt besten
Trauer um Horst Dieter Höttges die
Fußball-Legende ist im Alter von 79
Jahren gestorben seine größten Erfolge
feierte der Bremer im Nationaltrikot
erster als Europameister 1972 dann als
Weltmeister 1974 legendär seine
gefürchteten die im großen Respekt bei
seinem Gegnern brachten
der man nannte ihn deshalb den Eisenfuß
gegen höttkes zu spielen war nicht
lustig
und eine gute Nachricht zum Schluss die
Zahl der Kegelrobben in der Nordsee
steigt inzwischen auf über 10.000 Tiere
was so niedlich als Robbenbaby der
herkommt gilt allerdings als
Deutschlands größtes Raubtier denn eine
ausgewachsene Robbe kann bis zu 300 Kilo
wiegen die Kegelrobbe heißt übrigens
Kegelrobbe weil sie anders als der
ähnlich aussehende Seehund eine spitz
zulaufende Schnauze hat
beim Wetter bleibt es ungemütlich mehr
dazu gleich von essentielli Christian
Sievers hat um 21:45 Uhr das heute
journal für Sie auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter das Wetter bleibt
unbeständig aus dem Westen kommt der
Regen zum Beispiel sehen Sie hier im
Norden dieses Regengebiet was allmählich
ostwärts zieht im Laufe der Nacht aber
auch im Süden wird es regnen schauen wir
uns das im Detail an im Norden also
Schauer und Gewitter die ostwärts ziehen
und in der zweiten Nachthälfte sich dann
allmählich verabschieden und auch ganz
im Süden regnet es dazwischen ist es
überwiegend aufgelockert zwei tiefsten
Temperaturen von 9 Grad ganz im Westen
und 15 Grad am Oberrhein morgen dann
neue Schauer und Gewitter die tagsüber
durchziehen und dann verdichtet sich das
am Nachmittag und vor allem den
Abendstunden dann von Westen er neue
Gewitter und auch im Süden gibt es Blitz
und Donner dazwischen häufiger mal
Sonnenschein und das bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 27 Grad im Südwesten
und 18 Grad in Schleswig-Holstein ja
Mittwoch gibt's noch ruppiger zu kommen
weitere schauen und Gewitter auf die
können im unwetterbereich Liegen mit
Hagel Sturm und stark kriegen die ziehen
dann auswärts bei 18 bis 26 Grad und
danach wird es etwas ruhiger und am
Freitag heißt bis 31 Grad ein schönen
Abend